le corps en un virus de plus en plus
présent à madagascar plus de 85 cas
confirmés pour le moment l'état
d'urgence sanitaire a été décrété avec
confinement et couvre feu de nombreux
italiens sont bloqués sur l'île en
raison de la fermeture des frontières à
l'abbé licence avec entame en clair cela
devait être la dernière destination de
son voyage
fabio cet italien chef pizzaïolo de
métier est arrivé à madagascar il ya un
mois de ça le voilà bloqués sur place en
attendant la fin de la crise sanitaire
et la réouverture des frontières sur la
petite île de nosy bé la cuisine
italienne est très répandue fabio lui
est en vacances pour le moment
cuisinier saisonniers ils espèrent
pouvoir rentrer en italie pour y
travailler cet été pour le moment mon
projet pour le futur et de rentrer en
italie et de recommencer à travailler je
fais des saisons et ça devait démarrer
là enfin maintenant tout est arrêté
fabio est en contact tous les jours avec
ses proches en italie la situation
sanitaire dans son pays est bien pire
qu'à madagascar qui déplore plus de 80
cas confirmés pour le moment l'état
d'urgence sanitaire a été annoncé le 22
mars dernier tout comme le confinement
et le couvre feu ce lundi une première
personne n'a été diagnostiquée positive
au co vite 19 sur l'île de nosy-bé à
nosy bé la vie s'arrête à 20 heures
tout est fermé mais c'est bien comme ça
je préfère ça à like this fabio est loin
d'être le seul touriste italien à s'en
remettre à la ré ouverture incertaine
des voies aériennes pour rentrer chez
lui
emanuele et massimo oddo eux aussi dû
déposer leur valise face au canal du
mozambique les trois voyageurs ne se
connaissaient pas avant la crise du coït
désormais ils se retrouvent pour
partager lentilles pasto un guacamole
maison fabriqués avec des avocats frais
de la saison on a des amis qui viennent
me voir et
et en italie me disent déjà ça c'est
trop dangereux mais on sait pas on
essaie de garder les distances de la dg
j'utilise delà de l'eau de javel pour
désinfecter un peu j'espère vraiment que
quelque chose va aller mais sinon ça va
être vraiment le problème de son côté
massimo qui était parti pour trois mois
madagascar a vu la durée de son séjour
déjà doublé ingénieur de formation il
espérait développer une activité à
madagascar
mais avec la crise sanitaire et les
restrictions qu'elle engendre son projet
n'a pas pu aboutir à madagascar
la plupart des gens survivent avec moins
de deux dollars par jour
même dans ces conditions la solidarité
avec les étrangers bloqués sur place se
manifeste avec les amis j'arrive à vivre
on va dire un manière dignité aux voilà
je suis pas encore sous la route a
demandé de l'argent c'est quand même
loin
j'ai à remercier les malgaches qui est
mon speech in med et qui m'a donne à
manger et j'essaye les faire qu'est-ce
que je pose il faut aller à la pêche
maap fc faut ramasser des fruits on va
ramasser des fruits
bloqué dans l'un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde
expatrié touristes observent la crise en
italie de loin tout en espérant que la
pandémie ne se propage pas davantage
dans l'archipel malgache